welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about how all the
wonderful things that we thought humans
had invented throughout history were
actually just given to us by our
extraterrestrial masters who treat us
like toys in their very own dollhouse
nothing is real believe nothing
everything is just data
everything's a lie
everything's a lie into the video
seriously believe nothing um it's all
just one big simulation the matrix is
real the matrix is a documentary
honestly
my name is mt and i'm here today with my
big question brother offspring producer
brandon what's going on brandon hello mt
i'm so happy to be here today i'm so
glad that there's those eternals
watching out for us to make sure that we
could be here in this moment thanks
eternals for keeping us safe seriously
there are babysitters like i would be so
rambunctious if it wasn't for icarus and
cersei keep me in line i need i need my
parents yeah we would have been eaten up
by those deviants long long ago
seriously and i'm like thank god
so like i'm haitian so like haitian food
is delicious so i'd be eating first come
with that extra spice exactly some uh
some grill if you from my haitian people
out there some brio and some peace some
picklies on my head hit me with that big
question brandon
okay mt uh guys if you haven't guessed
we're gonna be talking about eternals
it's finally out in the theaters uh if
you haven't seen it yet go go watch it
and then come back to this video we're
gonna have so many videos on the channel
about the eternals it's eternal's time
baby yes eternal eternals videos forever
yes
forever forever
um but yeah now that we have the turtles
we have this like totally new
perspective that we can view the mcu
through especially as it is stretches
across the timeline of human history
right because the eternals they've been
there they've been watching us um and
then uh angelina jolie gave this recent
interview where she talks about that
there may have been moments throughout
time where the eternals played a part in
the development of technology uh whether
it was helped humanity or if it helped
some of the mcu heroes that we already
know uh some of our favorite heroes some
of the movies we already saw the
eternals might have been there they
might have been helping out we don't
know so it leads us to today's big
question what secret technological
assistance have the eternals provided
across time
this is a great question that opens up a
lot of many possibilities here because
as we already know angelina jolie
herself made the nintendo 64. so we
already know this has
she made it
i thought she made the gamecube now this
is a great question that opens up the
door to so many possibilities but let's
begin with that comicbook.com interview
that you mentioned brandon because it's
very important and in it angelina jolie
and sama hayek were asked about their
eternals characters and if there were
any other mcu heroes that they would be
impressed to meet and that's when
angelina kind of just reframes the whole
thing and says that we can assume that
the eternals have been in the background
the entire time and that they're aware
and know pretty much everybody and then
she says if you watch the other ones
we've been there the question is are
there certain things that fastos created
that you've been watching and thinking
it came from something else was it
actually fastos or has somebody else
been doing it all so this means that
there could be moments throughout time
where the eternals could have provided
some assistance in the development of
technology that helped humanity and this
could be both real world technology and
human history as well as moments that
we've seen in the mcu and we saw
examples of this in the film for example
it's implied that fastos played a role
in helping humanity discover how to
split the atom for instance which is a
really big discovery and a lot of [ __ ]
went down you know the the bombings of
his hiroshima nagasaki in japan during
world war ii happened because of that
which fasto seemed not too happy about
he seemed very yeah you could tell he he
regretted that i mean even the real
scientists who worked on
the manhattan project which led to the
atomic bomb they were pretty bummed out
about the final results too it was like
that whole thing of like we really want
to split the atom and then they did and
then they saw what they could do with it
and they were like oh boy what did we do
with big ole whoopsies fastos big o
whoops big old whoopsies
and we also did get that glimpse of
cersei helping the early humanity with
agriculture and farming and all that
stuff and uh i don't have a green thumb
at all so that would be a lot of help
thank you cersei you're so nice so this
means that it's time to open up your
history books and as we go through time
to try and pinpoint some key moments in
humanity's development that could have
had some eternal intervention things
like vibranium which is this huge
technological discovery in the marvel
cinematic universe the biggest one ever
everyone wants their that dang vibranium
rock they're obsessed over a frisbee for
the longest time before they gave it to
mr uh steve rogers so yeah thou shalt
not covet thy neighbor's vibranium no
don't do it because uh wakanda will come
after you and we'll stab you so watch
out captain carter because uh dora
malachi is coming for that ass i'm sorry
so yeah it's one of the most important
elements found on earth and legend tells
us that a meteor brought vibranium to
earth when it crashed in an area of
africa that we now know as wakanda but
could that just be just a legend is it
possible that the eternals created all
of that vibranium and gifted it to
mankind specifically the wakandan what
if that whole legend was like just a
legend it wasn't actually real like what
if they made the vibranium themselves
the eternals it's it's a legend that's
kind of passed down i mean at this point
uh in like modern history they should be
able to prove that there was a meteor
that hit at some point there would be
you know uh some sort of crater or
something i you know i i don't know
how they prove meteors
hit there's ways to tell geological
features that can you know verify a
theory i mean there's a lot there
because you know we saw on black panther
how they're still mining it out of the
earth and it's a big mine uh and it
seems like they got plenty to go around
but but could it have all just been
created by fast dose could have just
made all of that vibranium yeah i mean
there could have been like a celestial
machine or some sort like uh that you
use for a celestial purpose to create
this like magical rock this magical
material that served this huge purpose
so whether vibranium did arrive via
meteor or the eternals created it it's
possible that the eternals chose the
wakandans as the recipients of this
important metal and perhaps they saw the
wakandans as the chosen people of earth
which you know i would argue that they
are
they're pretty good they're pretty
they're the right people to choose if
you're going to choose some people oh
hell yeah they have kept that vibranium
a big old secret uh for many years so
good choice gods
certainly would have seen the eternals
as gods like everybody else did and
fastos could have shown them how to
utilize the material to their advantage
with the caveat is that they keep it a
secret from the rest of the world
because it's just this huge like new
cosmic material that the rest of the
world is not prepared for because
they're slowly trying to introduce
advancements to society they don't want
to push everything like all at once
right so it would make sense to do that
and they could also could have been the
one satisfying how to utilize the
heart-shaped herb to cultivate the power
of the black panther and all the future
tech advancements that came from wakanda
could have been set in motion by the
eternals showing the wakandans the
secrets of vibranium many many years ago
yeah if you know the ancient wakandans
come across these eternals right they're
going to assume they're gods especially
if they're flying around shooting lasers
and stuff and they're like oh boy this
is a lot of vibranium it's not from
earth these are things are too dum-dum
to handle this uh we gotta find some
good ones they they locate the local
wakandan tribe and they're like hey
we're gods uh hello and they're like
we're gonna show you this medal it's
pretty badass you can do a lot with it
we'll show you how to use it but you
cannot tell anybody if you do we're
gonna smite you because we're gods i
would love if if fastos introduced
himself like hi i'm fastest and they
were like bast boss did you say boss
he's like sure oh bass you can see
that's fine whatever tell me whatever
you want so yeah they show them how to
use it and they've kept it secret for so
long because you know the eternals
trusted they could tell that these were
the right people to handle this
technology i i do like the idea of the
eternals kind of using the country of
wakanda sort of like as a um i don't
know like sort of like a test it's like
this is what would happen if we did you
know give them technology before their
time it's like look at this african
nation they're super advanced this is
now the celestial plan so like we're
just gonna keep this nation over here as
i just said this is what happens if we
do things too early i do like that idea
but now let's go way back to a pivotal
discovery in human history the wheel i
don't know if you've heard of the wheel
i've seen a wheel or two in my time mt
i've seen i've seen a wheel or two oh
yeah steve jobs uh he announced it right
before he passed uh the wheel changed
the game but yeah what's important here
is not just the wheel itself but the
concept of fixing the wheel to an axis
like any old caveman can figure out a
wheel when they see a rock rolling down
a hill because like that's just gravity
it's like oh round of things go down the
hill when gravity pushes it down great
oogabooga but attaching a wheel to an
axle allowed more control and
versatility to harness the functional
benefits of a wheel and our oldest known
examples of humans harnessing this tech
is most likely the potter's wheel which
dates back around 4000 years bce in the
mesopotamia region and this could lead
to so many advancements in farming and
technology along with a greater
understanding of mathematical concepts
like geometry calculus and physics so it
makes sense that fast dose would see
some humans struggling with many of
their tasks including you know creating
clay pots to hold water and food and
would be like hey here you go dummies
here's the freaking wheel on an axis how
could you not think of this i can't even
believe it i'm gonna go back to my
flying spaceship you idiots it's a basic
basic development of technology
the eternals might have like got the
ball rolling you know if they're on
earth and they're seeing the you know
humans just being dumb they're like all
right just give
not much but get them started on
something see what they can do with this
all right i got one for you now okay
what you got let's discuss the printing
press oh gutenberg eh yes johannes
gutenberg uh invents it in 1440 a.d in
maine's germany
mainz
germany they probably hate that when
they throw over there like
why should they always make fun of mainz
that's the name of our city i hope
terence howard goes to maine's germany
one day and just be like i'm in maine's
maine
i hope terence howard goes to maine's
germany and never comes back
he's a very weird dude terrence howard
developed his own math one plus one
equals three look it up but no we're
talking about the printing press okay
and this invention i mean you probably
learned about it in history class or
maybe you slept through that lesson but
this invention it just changed how we
share literature and knowledge around
the world absolutely in fact
it's because of this invention that we
later get to like what they call the age
of enlightenment which promoted the
ideas of reason toleration
constitutional government personal
liberty if you're of a certain color uh
and progress across the world yeah
because it is the age of enlightenment
which really kicks off in around 18th
century europe it's not all
enlightenment for everybody i will say
that you know we didn't get everything
right but humans were trending upward at
that point they're starting to you know
understand things a little bit better be
a little bit nicer to each other
understand the need for societies on a
grander scale there were already like
printing presses when gutenberg came
around with his invention but they were
like much simpler there it took much
longer the printing price that gutenberg
invented was so technologically advanced
it could print so fast and so much uh
that it really did change the game i
could see the eternals playing a role
and helping gutenberg come up with this
idea you know being in the background
being like hey what if you you know
connected that to that
might never
so yeah i think of all the inventions of
humankind like i think the eternals i
think they would have pushed the
printing press because it was very
important for educating mass groups of
society really quickly oh yeah and it's
not just education it's more like it's
communication as well because as the
earth grew and like you know humanity
spread throughout the world
it's just more it's going to be harder
for these different communities to
communicate with one another and for
humanity to grow as uh us as people
because like if you're not communicating
with each other you can't grow and this
comes at like the end of the dark ages
too what they refer to as the dark ages
humanity was just kind of stuck in this
grind of like science really wasn't
advancing and you know society wasn't
advanced everyone's dying in it it's
just like a mess so this really helped
get us out of it and be like at least we
our knowledge can survive even if us
dumb dumb humans aren't going to survive
we know that sprites stories of the
eternals like translates into a
mythology in human history so like you
know the eternals know the importance of
the written work or the the spoken word
at the very least and how that can
affect cultures so like i feel like that
could be a good basis for like all right
let's get this printing press going but
hey let's talk about germs this time
around because
i mean the printing press was viral so
let's talk about jersey
i mean
not enough germ talk these days i mean i
don't even know no one's really talking
about barely barely talking about germs
we'll have to talk about germs now
specifically germ theory because there's
a whole theory on germs let me tell you
drum theory is a good name for like your
high school punk band oh yeah we are
gerb berry let's go one two three four
because you see prior to the year 1861
a.d it was relatively unknown just where
diseases came from a lot of people all
the time just thought that they came out
of thin air or maybe even the devil
which my mom still thinks oh god we're
going to see mephisto appear in ant-man
3 in the quantum realm as a writing
he's going to be a germ it's going to be
like i'm tired of being a germ i want to
be a demon and it wasn't until the
french microbiologist louis pasteur
invented his germ theory that we were
able to understand that diseases come
from microscopic organisms known as
pathogens and this discovery led to many
medical breakthroughs and a better
understanding of how diseases were
controlled treated and prevented and
this is why our milk gets pasteurized
through the development of the process
of pasteurization which would have many
benefits in the world of medicine as
well as agriculture and germ theory was
responsible for helping humanity curb
deadly epidemics like the plague
dysentery and typhoid fever so i think
we could consider this a big moment for
eternal intervention oh big time i mean
they really didn't understand just like
where diseases came from like you said
they thought it could just like appear
out of thin air it goes on to
change you know agriculture and like
food production and all sorts of things
uh come from just the idea of
understanding that yeah there's these
little pathogens these little germs that
are causing a lot of problems so maybe
wash your hands guys watch it seriously
wash your hands do the alphabet song
while you're washing your hands get all
those pathogens off of there doctors
thought it was crazy to wash their hands
before surgery i didn't see the point
you say why should i do that i got some
mustard i'm saving for later were they
literally like getting like their nasty
like freaking lunch on people's organs
yes they didn't wash their hands before
they would do surgeries and stuff yo why
does my baby smell like a subway
sandwich right
that's a great one mt but let's stay in
the medical world real fast let's talk
about penicillin what's very fascinating
about uh penicillin mt is that was
accidentally discovered back in 1928.
alexander fleming was a scottish
biologist who made the discovery of the
penicillin mold on accident when he
returned from a two-week vacation to
find that the penicillin mold had
prevented the growth of a bacteria
culture now some people are like oh he
was just a bad lab tech you know he
shouldn't have left them uh
you know he did a bad job but what i
think is interesting is because it was
on accident and there's like these two
weeks to where he's away from it maybe
like an eternal snuck in and did a
little
little magic a little eternal's magic to
show him like this is penicillin it
prevents the bacteria from growing and
then he comes back from vacation he's
like i'm well relaxed uh had a great
time at the beach and he's like what is
this boom we got penicillin right and it
would be a while before penicillin kind
of became mainstream uh but it was just
the the discovery of like uh antibiotics
that were was so important because then
you have like world war ii come in the
1940s and that's when it kind of goes
into mass production but without the
discovery of penicillin we wouldn't have
like the medical advances that we have
today so very important happened on
accident so i think uh an eternal might
have snuck in and made that penicillin
happen like we mentioned earlier um you
have to think that the eternals have
been around for so long and that they
did see this black plague just run amok
and kill so many people so like you know
i think that you know eternals like
vassals are probably like all right
let's do a little bit more foresight
into you know helping these helping
humanity fight off these mic this micro
world so i think that you know fastest
will probably be like all right this guy
seems like he's with it this guy seems
like he would accidentally find
his discover penicillin because this is
what he does moving on let's talk about
something less
germy and more nerdy because in 1822
mechanical engineer charles babbage
developed the first mechanical computer
which he called a different engine it
was capable of doing some polynomial
functions basically you know tabulating
some mathematical functions used in
engineering science and navigation and
this machine would later become a more
powerful device known as an analytical
engine and so history marches on until
we get to the very device that you're
watching this video on and it all
started with a different engine and it
was probably made thanks to good old
black man fastos thank you vastos
i think the internals could could tell
the importance that like
computing would make in humanity and
after you get like the analytical engine
it's tough to say who like invented the
more modern like paper punch computers
because like a bunch of people were
working on at the same time but they all
get inspired by this like analytical
engine which is just doing
simple equations on a grand scale but
let's get out of real human history it's
boring
let's talk about some more mcu places
where the tunnels could have popped up
one place i'm thinking is maybe with the
discovery of the pym particle okay did
the eternals like somehow get involved
with hank pym when he was like trying to
discover this particle you know right
could they have infiltrated shield like
gotta be like a low-level lab tech at
shield kind of sneaking in to work with
hank pym and maybe that's why you know
hank was so eager to put his name on the
particle he's like we're gonna call it
pimp articles i i found it i discovered
it and that's what we're gonna call it
but you know many many scientists
throughout time have like slapped their
name on something that really they're
you know lower level techs we're working
on and they're like this is mine now
i invented it i'm looking at you thomas
edison oh 100
100 was stealing stuff from his like
little lackeys being like you work for
me this is an edison product now edison
was a very interesting maniacal dude
watch out watch out for thomas edison
but hey speaking of all this technology
what about all that tech that old howard
stark invented over the years like were
they all his ideas or could the eternals
have provided some inspiration at some
point because when he developed the
shield for captain america that
contained all the vibranium the united
states was able to get their hands on is
it possible that fastos provided the
material to the americans but could they
have known that cap would play such a
pivotal role in saving the world there's
also that new element that howard stark
discovered but couldn't build in his
current technology and tony would end up
making that element in iron man 2. so is
it possible that the eternals provided
that inspiration or was that 100 howard
stark's idea i mean maybe when it was
clear that howard was going to go stick
to making weapons the eternals dipped
out and left him on his own because they
were like all right we knew that he had
the smarts to handle this cosmic
technology but he's clearly invested in
uh killing people so we can he's not the
one so that's why he couldn't develop
the new technology because he's just
like all right maybe they're just
waiting for his kid he's like you know
what let's just wait for a good old tony
to pop out i do love that idea that that
fast dose might have made the vibram to
make the shield because it was such a
hard element to get and ulysses claw was
around back then to help steal it out of
the country i guess i think it doesn't
make a lot of sense for the eternals to
to give the people outside of wakanda
just a little bit of a like a chance
it's like here we're not going to give
you all this cosmic rock but we're going
to give you a little bit just to see how
you guys um you know progress with it
and they used it very well they i mean
they didn't make a frisbee but it you
know it did help this captain america
save the world what if they even helped
howard with like the development like
the vita rays that they used when they
made captain america because that was
the one thing that changed the serum was
the vita rays uh because before the
serum wasn't working
yeah they could have helped with that
project maybe one of those guys in the
background was secretly
an eternal then when the guns went off
he's like i'm out of here bye
i'd like to think that he watched him
pull out the gun he's like
oh [ __ ] all right oh [ __ ] i gotta go to
the bathroom but yeah maybe they helped
with like the videos maybe they were
very pivotal in the creation of captain
america like oh for sure she's like
helping him get developed and created
that is our quick look at all the
possible interventions the eternals
could have made over the years if you
have your own theories please let us
know in the comment section below
because we love hearing from you our
beautiful nerd baby children but before
we continue our merch partners at epic
hero shop have all kinds of cool
clothing and gear inspired by your
favorite properties like a new eternal
shirt and merch inspired by wandavision
spiderman loki and so much more so grab
some early christmas gifts for your
nerdy loved ones or treat yourself to
cool t-shirts hoodies and stickers and
more all at new rockstarsmerch.com treat
yourself and before we dive into our
bite-sized questions next some words
from the people that help us bring big
question to you people like honey we've
all shop online and we've all seen that
promo code field taunt us at checkout
well thanks to honey manually searching
for coupon codes is a thing of the past
the eternals are living in that past and
they they were like yeah we don't do
that anymore maybe that maybe the
eternals invented honey i think so they
were tired of paying full price online
well honey is the free shopping tool
that scours the internet for promo codes
and applies the best one to your cart
and honey supports over 30 000 stores
online from tech and gaming sites to
popular fashion brands and food delivery
and when you check out at one of your
favorite sites the honey button drops
down and all you have to do is click
apply coupons wait a few seconds as
honey searches for coupons and if it
finds a working coupon you'll see the
prices drop recently at new rockstars
off-screen producer zach used honey to
save 10 bucks on some new shoes and
those shoes look even better knowing
that i know that he saved 10 on them so
if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out on some
free savings it's literally free and
installs in a few seconds and by getting
it you'll be doing yourself a solid and
supporting the show and we've never
recommend something that we do not use
ourselves we seriously love honey it's a
great product so get honey for free at
joinhoney.com big question that is
joinhoney.com
question fresh from san diego california
comes the only sunglasses brand you're
ever going to wear again for eternity
that's right blenders eyewear here at
new rockstars we got a pair of the moon
dog style and boy do we really like them
they're sturdy and stylish and perfect
to wear when carousing around town
chase fisher started blenders by selling
his beachy shades out of a backpack
while doubling as a surf instructor on
pacific beach his goal was to create an
adventurous mid-priced eyewear option
with the same cool factor as other
leading styles but unlike expensive big
brand shades that you've probably lost
or smashed in the past blenders are
actually affordable so you're not going
to cry as much when the inevitable
happens we're not saying you're not
gonna sit on them but when you do it'll
be less painful blender's team of
in-house designers are constantly coming
out with new styles from orange
polarized wrap-arounds tortoise shell
frames with purple lenses to classic
gold arms on black lens and it's not
just sunglasses folks blenders has
prescription glasses readers and blue
lights as well as a snow collection with
goggles and accessories live life in
forward motion with blenders today to
score fifteen percent off your blender's
purchase visit
blenderseyeware.com and enter the promo
code big question vip that's
blenderseyewear.com
code big question vip for 15 off
blenders rocked with pride worldwide
and this episode is also brought to you
by arcane a new really cool animated
netflix original series from the
creators of league of legends arcane is
a nine episode three-part series that
follows the story of two league of
legends champions that you know and love
vi and powder as they go on a series of
life-changing adventures so whether
you're a longtime league of legends
player or are new to runeterra you're
going to enjoy the series it has
beautiful animation and action-packed
stories that are going to keep you at
the edge of your seat and this series
has intertwining stories about other
league of legends characters like
heimerdinger and jace so dive into the
stories behind one of the most played
games of all time and discover the
secrets of the piltover and it's under
city and watch this series and prepare
for the epic battle that is only just
beginning and arcane is now streaming
exclusively on netflix so please go
check it out because it's really great
now it is time for our bite size
questions brandon are you ready i'm
ready are you ready to eat
them
here we go that's so bite-sized so
bite-sized and accessible delicious like
a tater tot here we go brandon how does
superman fit his cape underneath his
clothes and this is from spoon fiesta on
discord thank you spoon fiesta i like a
good fork fiesta but spoon fiestas are
pretty good too you know what about a
spork fiesta anyways yeah so we all you
know we all know
superman he likes to pal around town has
clark kent and he's got his like suit
underneath them the whole time you may
think he changes in a phone booth that's
kind of like apocryphal that was more of
an underdog thing and then it's also
like kind of a myth around metropolis
that he does the whole phone booth thing
he can really he's so fast he can change
wherever he doesn't need the phone booth
it's true use it in the show it's not a
big deal but he we you know superman
he's got this rolodex full of godlike
abilities from flying to super speed to
heat vision to super hypnosis i mean the
guy's got all these crazy powers but
even the smartest of us old humans has
got to wonder how the man of steel keeps
that billowing red cape like tucked
under his clark kent suit which is
already pretty tight and you know what i
mean seriously well one thing's for sure
nobody's gonna be looking at your face
mom where's where's that cape going and
he's also got those big red boots right
where where are those going have we
finally found the super-sized plot hole
from the last son of krypton
well not so fast right because those
boots were not made for walking those
boots were made to fly
they're boots um you may think you oh we
caught them we got we gotta they didn't
figure this out no they figured it out
the comics have an answer for us folks
during a run of the superboy comics back
in the 1970s they would do these
features in the back called the superboy
legend and these would explain some of
the components of superman's backstories
you know they did one about crypto the
dog one about mom and pop kent uh but
one of these superboy legends features a
story on the origin of the superman
costume itself
you see
in the rocket that carried cal-el to
earth there were plenty of unique and
versatile kryptonian materials these
included a red yellow and blue blanket
old pocket somehow figured out that
these materials had interesting
properties
including being impervious to damage
from pitchforks shotgun blasts tnt
explosions you know uh he got a lot of
downtime on the farm
he's like what do these blankets do i
can't blow him up um his wife is like
look at these cute blankets shooting
shoot it martha
shoots the blanket so they got these
blankets and they're like oh this this
is pretty strong material we have this
baby who's flying around and might kill
himself because they didn't know how
strong he was yet maybe we should make
him a little costume out of these this
stuff but you know ma can't she can't
just like cut the blankets up because
you know they're indestructible but she
could unravel the fabric to make like
strings of yarn or material or just
strings that she could then weave into a
costume for superboy again this is like
the comics in the 70s a lot of
suspension of disbelief on like how this
works i can't break it but i can just
unspool it and make it into something
else i can weave it into something else
right
and then in this material because again
it's like special kryptonian material uh
it would also grow with super boy as he
became a superhero
okay and then good old pacquiao you know
he's he's rifling around taking apart
that rocket and he found some like
rubberized material
they call it like that because you know
it's alien material that's kind of like
rubber that's what they make the red
boots out of and the yellow belt wow
again this was covered in like two pages
on the super boy legend so we're filling
in a lot of holes here
um but because these are again these are
fancy kryptonian textiles they have some
really interesting properties
like the ability to be compressed into
like a very very small size now how
small you might be asking yourself well
superman was able once like pressed down
his suit
to about the size of like a piece of gum
and then he kind of stuck it in his
mouth yeah it's really crazy he can just
kind of smash his smooth his suit down
into these like tiny little sizes
because i think he was like going to
like a karate class with lois lane or
something he's like he's got to change
into his ghee but he's like i got the
suit on underneath
he like presses the suit down into like
a little pill size sticks in his mouth
and i think he accidentally swallowed it
and he had to go to the hospital i don't
know wait did he was he really going to
a karate class i'm pretty sure that was
i didn't read the whole comic but i
think that was like the storyline
hey hey
you lose concentration of fighting your
dead meat yes that's it
imagine being the one fighting superman
in a karate class like that is so wet
that's not fair that's not uh
this is all this i mean these kind of
crazy scenarios are what happens when
you have to write a comic book for like
nearly 90 years like you're running out
of ideas for sure he smashes it down he
puts in his mouth
it's like superman resurrected what do
we do next oh put him in a karate class
yeah i don't know put him across has he
taken karate yet is he one chest all
right put him in the corner and then
like when the sue is like exposed to the
sonic i guess it just grows back to
normal size i don't know um
that's that's how it happened
what i also love when researching this i
discovered that because you might be
wondering okay so he's able to just like
kind of cram the
everything underneath his suit right
because it's special kryptonian material
he can just kind of squish it down and
it fits under so the cape is just under
there he's just crammed it in it's under
the suit that's that's the answer but
mock good old ma kent when she was
making this outfit uh and she makes the
cake she like sews a pocket into the
cape so when he takes off his clark kent
clothes he puts them like in a pocket
what but they also say that like he
sprays material on his like some special
material on his car clark kent clothes
so he can also kind of smash that stuff
up like one thing described him like
taking the shoes and like pressing them
into little wafers i don't know man so
the whole time you see superman flying
around he's got a a pocket in his cage
that has his clark
he's clark kent costume in it which is
uh
wow
you know i really hope that the next
superman movie goes into this i hope
it's a whole scene yes where there's
some my cat to pocket just taking apart
this spaceship
[Laughter]
just like a whole like a blue collar
just like hard-working family just take
your time oh podcast's like maybe i can
blow up this believe me i don't know i
like to think of amanda steele when he's
just like he's like punching he's
fighting you know he's
he's fighting zod like through the city
and the whole time his little outfits in
his pocket he's [ __ ]
that what if it just like fell out
inside like what the hell was that he's
like
he's like timeout my clothes fell out
i lost my clothes
he's like all right time out he just
collects his clothes
i mean it's a really silly answer but
there's your answer they got an answer
for you wow
hey bad you like you said these superman
comics have been around for so long that
it makes sense that these like silly
explanations have come up because like
they had these letter sections in comics
and like people were writing in like all
these questions so like they've had to
answer all these questions over the
course of like 100 years of superman so
yeah thank you for that i had no idea
about them yeah i didn't know either
when i told you that i was like this is
fascinating
uh but honestly the karate class that
did it for me i just i love that fact
superman of karate class oh my god i
thought superman fighting uh muhammad
ali was unfair but that was already wow
[Laughter]
but all right brandon here's your second
bite-sized question brandon are there
any other fictional medals in the marvel
universe besides vibranium adamantium
and
and this is from our favorite
iajsmith24 always holding it down with
the questions thank you iag smith you
can bet there's other fictional medals
out there oh boy you can be oh yeah for
sure you know in iron man 2 we saw we
were talking about earlier but we saw
tony create that new element
uh thanks to those leftover plans from
pa
and he never he never names the new
element in the movie and jarvis is just
like you've created a new element he
never names that new element that he
like replaces the palladium and his arc
reactor but uh there was that comic that
came out based on fury's big week where
they joked that he tried to call it
badassium who was having trouble getting
the rights to that name or getting the
patent through i don't know but yeah so
there is that metal that we
we've seen that one in the mcu but
they're of course in the comics there's
a ton of other like fictional metals so
i'll go through a few of them there's
carbonadium which is uh it's basically
the soviet version of adamantium
and it makes up if you know omega red
that badass character it makes up the
coils and omega red it's like a little
more flexible
than uh adamantium so it that's how he
has coils instead of claws but yeah the
soviets they were trying to make
knockoff animation that's what they got
and then there's nanominium which is a
metallic substance with anti-magical
properties uh there's plan danium uh
which is a strong metal alloy that the
space knights armor is made out of out
as well as oh my god i love the space
nights man yes i'm glad you brought that
up well they're made of plandanium
and then there's epidurium which is a
super rare metal that is used in the
synthetic skin of the life model decoys
and you know we mentioned adamantium
already you mentioned it in your
question but there's also adam mantine
and adam 18 is the golden divine version
of adamantium and it makes up hercules
golden mace and it that yeah like it's
it's gold instead of silver like
adamantium and it's so powerful it's
been known to be resistant to material
shifts or matter state changes so like
those kind of crazy powerful people who
can manipulate matter and on a molecular
level it's been known to resist that
like that's how powerful it is uh so
very very strong stuff very cool um and
then there's some more mystical marvel
medals out there you know there's like
the galactic glaze that covers the
silver surfer's body and his board um
but you know this is a bite size we
can't get into all of them so we'll have
to save all the other metals for another
day but those are some of the other
metals you can find out there in the
marvel universe like literally galactic
glaze sounds like a dunkin donut uh i
know doesn't that sound
let me get that uh delicious
surfer galactic glace that sounds they
sell that galactic glaze out of the
wheat stores out here in california man
well thank you brandon for your always
amazing insightful answers to our big
bite questionable our small bite-sized
questions well now it is time for our
box of scraps bran
shoes crabs please it's a bag of scraps
well brandon if you were an internal
what historical event would you like to
be present for but not meddle in
like any historical event throughout
history yeah that's a good uh box of
scraps question mt because then i don't
feel the pressure to go fix some of the
wrong yeah throughout history which i
would love to do but i can't do it
because i'm an eternal and no deviants
were involved
no deviants were involved
i think a really fun thing to see would
be to go back
to you know i love going to a
renaissance fair but what if you just
went back to the renaissance you know
what i mean just go and hang out
a little renaissance italy maybe just
you know view view leonardo at work you
know maybe view michelangelo
michelangelo at work not talking into
turtles i'm talking like a real artist
you know be like a patron of the arts to
be like ah yes leonardo this helicopter
you've designed is quite something is a
little money to go build it you know
maybe get that tech going along but it'd
be it'd be cool to see like the real
renaissance i mean it's going to smell
terrible but that's okay for sure i'll
get used to that there'll be some good
food you know some good entertainment
they'll be playing that loot you know
they'll be playing
the lyre
singing songs it'll be maybe some
joustings going on i don't know who
knows the renaissance was like 400 years
i'll pick a good time to go during that
and just hang out and have a good time
that's a good one oh man that's a really
good one the renaissance like literally
so much popped off during the
renaissance i would love to talk to you
um what's his name leonardo da vinci
i'll be like where's where's the blood
of jesus
[Laughter]
where's the da vinci code i saw the
movie and leonardo was like what's a
movie what's the movie who's the tom
hanks
who's a thomas hank
sorry i'm sorry all our italian viewers
i'm so sorry
i can't do italian at all
what would i choose i think i would
choose sort of like in a similar vein
i would probably just hang out with a
bunch of like greek
um philosophers honestly just like
attend one of their like
little seminars that they gave out in
public and just be like oh the wisdom
because i'm a huge fan of just like
looking at like old wisdom from the past
i'm a huge like if you guys don't know
about stoicism you guys should look into
it because like marcus aurelius
epictetus um all these like uh famous
stoic philosophers um really knew how to
live life in my opinion and like they
had these really interesting um like
ideas about philosophy and like the
actual tenets of cognitive behavioral
therapy are in stoicism so i think i
would just go either back in time to the
stoic philosopher days or like the greek
you know
we're just going to talk about
philosophy basically because i'm just a
sucker for philosophy and then and then
empty you'd slip up and you'd be like
well you know the earth goes around the
sun and they'd be like what what
man
kill this man
heretic
heretic burn him
um but yeah i think that it'd be fun i
just i just like learning about i don't
know little like concepts and like
philosophy and all that stuff so
that's me that'd be cool that like old
painting of everyone sitting around
talking yeah and socrates and stuff it
always just be hanging out in the back
of that painting just like having a good
time
just me and my big black bald head like
yeah and you could just like blow their
minds they'd be like ah the stars the
spirits of our ancestors and you're like
actually they're giant balls of gas
millions of miles away and they'd be
like burn this man
well that is it for this episode of big
question i want to thank off-screen
producer brandon for joining me this
episode please follow him at
grindenberric on twitter he is an
amazing man he does a lot of amazing
stuff and so please follow them there
follow me at mastertainment if you want
to see me tweet some really weird [ __ ]
most importantly follow new rockstars
wherever we are especially on twitter
and on youtube and when you do on
youtube make sure to hit that
notification bell so you can get
notifications every time we upload a
video and please of course hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com so you can get cool
shirts like this so girls can talk to
you um and think that you're super cool
and if you if you're not into girls
it'll be whatever whoever you're into
that will think you're super cool
because you are and i love her
but anyway thank you guys so much for
watching uh we really do love you and
we'll see you guys later bye
[Music]
you